There's a new reality television
program, and it's
called the Blue-- I should
probably write it in blue--
but it's called the Blue
Forehead Room.
And what they do in this reality
television program--
and you'll have to bear with me,
because the show probably
wouldn't be that interesting
to watch-- but it's
interesting to predict
what happens.
What they do is, they
take a room.
They'll call it the blue
forehead room.
And let's see, that's kind of
a top view of the room.
And let's say there's
a door here.
None of this is relevant
to the actual problem.
This is the door, right there.
And what they do is they get 100
perfect logicians to sit
in this room, in a circle.
So they're all sitting in
a circle in this room.
Now, before the game even
starts, before they even enter
the room the first time, the
logicians are told two things.
They're told, One: that at
least one of you has your
forehead painted blue.
At least one of you has your
forehead-- And they all get
their foreheads painted, so that
obviously if you're the
only guy who has your
forehead painted.
But you just don't know
what color it is.
So all of them have different
color foreheads.
Or, we don't know.
But all they're told
is, obviously I've
painted your forehead.
At least one of the people in
the room that you will enter
will have their forehead
painted blue.
And then they're also told that
as soon as you deduce
that your forehead is blue, you
need to leave the room.
And what's going to happen is--
and it's very important
that I set this up properly.
They're all outside
of the room.
No-one's inside the room.
And let's say they're
blindfolded.
And while they're blindfolded,
they essentially have the
thing painted onto
their forehead.
So they can't see the paintbrush
or anything.
So they really don't know what's
on their forehead.
And then after that, they
all enter the room.
And they all sit in a circle
like this, so that they can
all look at each other.
And let's say when they enter,
the lights are off.
So the lights are off, and then
the protocol is that the
lights will be turned on, and
then they can all look around
at each other.
There's no reflective
surfaces.
They can't look into each
other's eyes and try to see
the reflection.
No tricks like that.
There are no mirrors
in this room.
Nothing like that.
All they can do is look
at each other.
So, just as an example,
let's say that
this is me right here.
As soon as the lights get turned
on the first time, I'll
be able to look at all the
other people in the room.
And I could see, it'll be pretty
obvious to me if anyone
has a blue forehead.
Maybe that guy has one,
that guy doesn't.
I don't know, right?
And I can see them.
I can't see my own forehead.
And what happens is, then they
will turn off the lights, and
the way they're going to do it
is you have to leave the room
after you have realized that
you have a blue forehead.
So for example, let's say I
enter into the room, and
because I'm a perfect logician
I see things that allow me to
perfectly deduce that I
have a blue forehead.
Then what they're going to do
is they're going to turn off
the lights again.
And then, if I know that I have
a blue forehead while the
lights are turned off, I
would leave the room.
And then when they turn the
lights back on, I'd be gone.
So there would be no Sal here.
So let's say there were 100
before, then there would be 99
guys sitting in the room.
Right?
As soon as I realize I have a
blue forehead, when the lights
get turned off, I leave. And
just remember these are
perfect logicians.
So everyone in the room.
And not only are they all
perfect logicians, but they
all know that everyone else
is a perfect logician.
So, everyone is also told, and
this is true, everyone is a
perfect logician.
Which means they have infallible
powers of logic.
So my question to you-- Just
remember, I have each of these
perfect logicians.
We set them up outside of the
room, paint their foreheads.
They're blindfolded.
They have no clue.
Then we have all of them walk
into a dark room, sit in a
circle like this.
And then what we tell them is,
as soon as you realize that
you have a blue forehead, as
soon as you have a blue
forehead, you have to
leave the room.
Now my question to you is, let's
say that we've actually
painted everybody's
forehead blue.
What happens?
So remember, this is what we've
told each of the people.
Right?
As soon as you realize your
forehead is blue,
you leave the room.
And now I've just asked you, the
producers like to really
play with these logicians.
They've actually painted
everybody's forehead blue.
So when everyone goes in the
room the first time, what's
going to happen?
Let's say I'm one of
the logicians.
This is me right here.
As soon as I open my eyes, I'm
going to see 99 other fellow
logicians with blue foreheads.
And then, maybe I can somehow
deduce something about my own.
I don't think you can.
And the lights will go off.
And then if I haven't deduced
anything about my own blueness
of my forehead, then they'll
turn the lights back on.
And then maybe some other
guy will have left.
I don't know.
Or maybe not.
And then I'll see the
same 99 guys again.
And that'll just keep occurring
until something happens.
And my question to you
is what happens?
When?
And why?
I'm thinking whether I should
give you a hint right now.
Well let me tell it
to you this way.
That's the problem.
You should be able
to solve it.
And just so you know where this
came from, if I remember
correctly I think this was
on a computer science
exam I had at MIT.
So just so you know, this
isn't just for fun.
I don't want to go into all of
the applications that this
type of problem can apply to,
because that by itself would
be a bit of a hint.
So if you don't want a hint,
turn off the video
now or pause it.
If you do want a hint, I'm
about to give it to you.
So my hint is-- and remember
turn this off if you don't
want to hint-- but the hint is
what happens when there are
less than 100 people.
So I gave the situation where
we have 100 logicians.
But this problem is actually a
lot easier if you try it with
a smaller number.
Anyway I'll see you in
the solution video.